and so what are we gonna what are we
gonna say that that I'm feel myself
becoming infatuated with a 20 year old
girl we have to hand it to you Woody
Allen you sure know a thing or two about
age gaps you've played the much older
man enough times in your movies to have
nailed that role and when it comes to
your real-life relationships you're
certainly letting life imitate art like
marrying your long-term partners adopted
daughter who happens to be nearly 35
years younger than you that's almost as
big a gap as the characters you play so
many Hollywood movies have a male lead
that is much older than his female
counterpart but your jaw will drop when
you find out just how big the age
difference is between the actors playing
those on-screen couples keep watching
the end to discover which leading lady
dropped out of a movie because she
wasn't digging the age gap and which
other actor was happy to take her place
it's one thing when the age gap between
actors means the male lead could be the
female leads father but it's a whole
other ballgame when he's technically old
enough to be her grandfather you'd think
that kind of romance would be a bit of a
stretch even for the movie business
however that's exactly what happened
when Sean Connery and Catherine
zeta-jones acted opposite each other in
entrapment these two had nearly four
decades between them when they shot the
movie Shawn was 68 and catherine was 29
when they filmed the 1999 crime thriller
that adds up to a 39 year age difference
we'll let that one sink in for a moment
of course Catherine wouldn't mind such
an age gap on the big screen after all
she has a large age difference in her
real-life relationship with Michael
Douglas
this couple proves that love knows no
boundaries when it comes to age as there
are exactly 25 years between them and
they first met in 1998 the year before
entrapment was released it's like it was
all meant to be and I have a lot of
mutual respect
while the age difference between Sean
Connery and Catherine zeta-jones is easy
to spot out that isn't always the case
for some on-screen couples sometimes
actors look like they're pretty much in
the same age bracket so the big age gap
comes as even more of a shock when the
truth gets out that's the case with the
stars of edge of tomorrow Tom Cruise was
51 when filming the 2014 movie while
Emily Blunt who was 31 I volunteered I'm
not walking away tom is one of those
actors who has managed to age really
well like Brad Pitt and Leonardo
DiCaprio but we'll get back to those two
a-listers a little later in the video
when we see Tom Cruise acting alongside
a love interest who's two decades
younger than him we don't bat an eyelid
as it's not so obvious that he's old
enough to be your father it's also
interesting that Tom and Emily's
characters flipped the age gap on its
head after all it's Emily's character
that's in charge training Tom's
character to fight aliens in the
meantime you need to figure out a way to
get us off that Beach Woody Allen and
Juliette Lewis gives sean.conner and
Catherine zeta-jones a run for their
money by having 37 years between them
although they fall short of Sean and
Catherine's age gap by two years their
age difference in husbands and wives is
a lot more scandalous that's because
Juliet was just 19 when she acted in the
1992 movie while woody was 56 she was
still a teenager and very much looked
like one Woody Allen of course knows all
about age gaps in the 1979 movie
Manhattan he was 43 while his love
interest mariel hemingway
was 17 in the 1992 movie husbands and
wives what his character leaves his wife
to follow a flirtation with Juliet's
character and there was a bit of life
imitating art going on Woody's wife in
the film was his long-term partner in
real life Mia Farrow around the time of
the movie's release would he left Mia to
marry her adopted daughter soon he
Previn who was 21 at the time woody and
soon-yi have nearly a 35 year age gap I
have an adult relationship with suni
we mentioned Brad Pitt earlier and now
we're revealing the age gap between him
and his on-screen lover
Brad was 40 when the 2004 film Troy was
released while Rose Byrne was just 25
that's a 15 year age gap it's not as big
as many of the others on our list but
it's an interesting one to include
that's because it shows just how well
Brad is aged you wouldn't think he was
finishing up high school when Rosa's
being born now would you when you look
at the age difference in that context it
brings it home in a whole new light you
think he's so different from a thousand
others in real life brad has been in
relationships with more than a 10-year
age difference he was born in December
1963 while his ex-wife Angelina Jolie
was born in June 1975 that's an 11 and a
half year age gap the same goes for Tom
Cruise he was born in 1962 while his
ex-wife Katie Holmes was born in 1978
that's more than a 16 year age
difference I feel I feel fortunate if
we're talking about big age gaps in real
life as well as in movies then we have
to include Johnny Depp and Amber Heard
they starred together in the 2011 movie
The Rum Diary johnny was 48 and amber
was 25 making it a 23 year age
difference even for an actor like Johnny
who has aged incredibly well you can't
help but notice an age gap like that and
it wasn't just an on-screen age
difference to know each other as their
feelings for one another developed in
real life too as with so many co-stars
intense emotions grew between Johnny and
amber the two actors fell in love
proving that an age difference can't
stop deep feelings the couple got
married in 2015 when johnny was 51 and
amber was 28 however their love story
soon turned sour when amber filed for
divorce from Johnny after just one year
of marriage with accusations flying
against each other they sadly didn't get
the happy ending they'd hoped for
we're keeping with the theme of actors
who have big age gaps not only on-screen
but in real life too however unlike
Johnny Depp it's not with the same woman
off and on screen for Harrison Ford on
screen Harrison played opposite and
hitch in the movie six days seven nights
he was 55 years old and she was 28 when
they filmed the 1998 movie making it a
27 year age difference
thanks to Harrison's boyish looks
however the age difference wasn't as
obvious as it could have been as for his
personal life Harrison is married to
Ally McBeal star Calista Flockhart she's
his third wife and the couple has a 22
year age gap he was born in July 1942
while she was born in November 1964 they
began dating after meeting at the 2002
Golden Globe Awards in 2010 the
age-defying couple chose to tie the knot
and they are still going strong in 2020
I'm grateful and happy thank you when
Jeff Bridges at Maggie Gyllenhaal filmed
the 2009 movie crazy heart he would have
been 59 and she would have been 31 that
made the stars 28 years apart which is a
very significant age gap
Jeff was born in December 1949 while
Maggie was born in November 1977 but get
this some movie makers think that his
female actors reach their mid-30s
they're too old to play the love
interest of a much older man six years
after the movie was released Maggie made
some fascinating revelations about how
Hollywood views female actors as they
get older in 2015 Maggie revealed in an
interview that a Hollywood producer told
her that she was too old to play love
interest of a 55 year old man she was
just 37 at the time Maggie admitted
there are things that are really
disappointing about being an actress in
Hollywood and these things surprise her
all the time like that astonishing
judgment by the Hollywood producer first
of all it made her feel bad then it made
her feel angry but in the end it made
her laugh too misogyny was on all of our
minds
in the 2013 movie third person Liam
Neeson plays an author who's left his
wife and is now involved with a
journalist played by Olivia Wilde when
they filmed the movie Liam would have
been about 61 while Olivia would have
been around 29 Liam was born in June
1952 and Olivia was born in March 1984
that places them nearly thirty two years
apart the actor that plays William's
wife in the film Kim Basinger was born
in December 1953 so unsurprisingly
they're much much closer in age how
she's the love of your life why would
that bother me as we've seen with other
movies on this list the other woman
character is often much younger than the
man that was the case with Woody Allen
and Juliette Lewis's characters - in
real life Olivia's two main men have
both been nearly a decade older than her
Olivia's first husband was born in
November 1975 her longtime fiance the
actor and comedian Jason Sudeikis was
also born in 1975 he's one of the best
improvisers in the world Leonardo
DiCaprio was one of those people who
doesn't seem to age sure he's not the
fresh-faced young man we saw in the 1997
movie Titanic he was just 22 when he
shot that film but today he looks a lot
younger than his actual age so when he's
cast alongside actors who are much
younger than him it's not jarring take
his leading lady in the wolf of Wall
Street for example Leo who was born in
1974 was 38 when filming the 2013 movie
Margot Robbie who was born in 1990 was
around 22 years old when she was cast as
his on-screen wife that's 16 years
between them and yet the couple didn't
come off as inappropriate in the film in
fact they seemed evenly matched that's
right that's right the pair starred on
screen together again in the 2019
Quentin Tarantino movie Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood Brad Pitt also starred
alongside them making many movie fans
dreams come true as for life imitating
art Leo and Margo aren't a couple but
Leo's penchant for youthful girlfriends
has made headlines more times than we
can count but Margaret doesn't mind the
large age gap because about a year later
she starred opposite an actor who is
even older than Leo I'm sorry wait
if you thought a 16 year old age gap was
a bit of a stretch then what about
adding another six years on to that as
we know Margot was born in July 1990
Will Smith was born in September 1968
that makes him nearly 22 years older
than Margot but that didn't stop
Hollywood movie makers from cashing the
Paris on-screen lovers in the 2015 movie
focus we're pretty used to leading men
being much older than leading women by
now but what makes this movie
particularly interesting is that the
original female lead wasn't digging the
age gap Kristen Stewart is only three
months older than Margot Robbie being
born in April 1990 and Kristen was
slated to star and focus before Margot
came along but it's been reported that
when Will Smith became engaged with the
project Kristin chose to drop the movie
its allegedly because she felt that the
age difference between her and Will
would be too big how they go which age
gap surprised you the most and what do
you think of Hollywood's habit of
casting much older man opposite much
younger women be sure to sound off in
the comments please give us a big thumbs
up and remember to hit that subscribe
button to be the first to watch our
latest videos thanks for watching see
you next time on the things
you